all right i've just tweeted this out all
right we are live thank you eric
we are live on youtube and we are doing
an experiment
and as
you know most experiments fail
uh so hopefully that's a huge confidence
booster thank you brian for that
you're not even a physicist come on man
you're well you told me the way that i
was now you're telling me to say i'm
sorry i'm just lost
all right well i still don't see you
let's see on twitter
spaces we're trying to do a joint
session here
if you can uh oh let me see if there's a
request nope there's no work all right
join the twitter space there you are all
right now i'm gonna make you
a co-host
send co-host invite there we go
all right
let's see can pete can you hear us on
twitter well be hard to know if they can
i'm going to turn down my microphone
yep there we go
well we are live
and today is a special day
today
is the birthday of yours truly
which occurred way back on september 9th
1971.
uh i don't remember much from that time
period but eric does uh maybe maybe a
little bit more he was all of five years
old or so
and uh and i think i'm solid in 1971. i
say it again i think i'm starting to get
pretty solid on 1971. it was an
interesting year oh turn your uh mic uh
your mic is muted on twitter spaces my
friend
um because it's feedback and i can't get
the twitter spaces volume to zero which
is a strange thing so i put it in a
briefcase what should i be doing brian i
would put it yeah put it away move it
somewhere not too far away but unmute so
people can hear you on twitter at least
and then okay i will
sorry if i unmute you're gonna get a
feedback loop
um
if you put it far enough away and mute
it it should be okay
sorry okay
but if you don't unmute it they won't be
able to hear you
and you can see eric's beautiful
microphone there that was a gift on his
birthday
when he turned the double nickel
not too long ago all right there we go
all right we'll see if this actually
works who knows if it'll work
uh is this any better
yep this is better for me uh say one
more thing
and now happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
happy 50th birthday
dear brian happy birthday to you
thank you my friend it is great to be
with good friends on a special
auspicious occasion
just after the new year shanatova let me
be the first to wish you a happy 13
billion
uh 900 million 5782
it's that's what we cosmologists now say
i see
and can we fine tune this to the to the
jewish calendar or what
yeah we synchronize there's some
calibration error in the very beginning
from lorenz factor did i ever tell you
my lorenz factor story no
there i am minding my own business
wandering the fourth floor of the
american natural history museum
in new york and we're going past all the
dinosaur fossils and i see this very
proper firm couple
orthodox jews wandering around and i
said look
um
i mean i just asked you guys a question
as a co-religionist uh you guys take the
the scripture more seriously than i do
do you believe in the you know the
origin story is told in in our sacred
texts they said of course
i said how do you square the fossil
record with modern science
and
they said well we thought about that for
a long time and we decided that if god
was moving sufficiently quickly
relative to earth
then the lorentz factor could account
for it all through time dilation
so they worked out the speed of god
[Laughter]
that is uh that's quite admirable i have
to say it's better than the you know
god put the dinosaurs and made them look
like they were old that that kind of uh
time dilation is not is not something
you might as well learn a little bit of
physics
that's right although i did try to use
once the redshift and blueshift effect
for a radar gun with a with a police
officer and those were two pretty lonely
nights in prison and
it's funny i use the radar gun example
as a an example of a co-vector something
that eats velocity vectors along a
particular axis and spits out a number
in a linear fashion we don't think about
what does a covector look like but in
some sense
a contravariant tensor whatever you want
to call it
a good example of that is a radar gun
yes and radar of course one of the two
twin
uh inventions of world war ii that
enabled the uh the victorious uh allied
forces to win and by my reckoning eric
and by some of your local tweets recent
tweets
that might have been one of the last
things america really won
maybe the space program you can argue
that was incredibly successful i want to
ask you just
yes or no are you optimistic about the
future
no
okay do you think the next 50 years will
look anything at all like the preceding
50 years of life of myself on this
planet not a chance
and i couple those two things the
pessimism or lack of optimism to be
accurate and no no it's not lack of
optimism it's you're asking me about
relative probabilities and i do believe
that most branches of the decision tree
are pretty pretty sour at the moment it
is not to say that we don't have
remarkable possibilities but i don't see
anyone in a class of people who can move
the d
the dial procedurally
interested in any of the ideas that come
from people who might be able to
really contribute something new so i see
that in general the people who are
sitting in the chairs that can get
things done
or who can command those resources
are very much trying to make sure that
they're on the part of the titanic that
goes down last
but they don't seem to be interested in
trying to get off so it's so amazing
because you know today my in-laws called
me and and wish me a very happy
california admission day you know today
was uh september 9th is the day that
california our great state was admitted
to the union and i used to look at
california when i was a wee lad
and think i'll never be lucky enough to
live there and i'll never be i have the
good fortune to live there you've lived
here for a good deal of your life um how
do you think the local factors are
affecting your you know kind of forecast
or your optimism slash pessimism
relativity oh i don't think it's local
at all i mean we've got a global
pandemic
um
we have
we used to have a lot of really evil
leaders that were really talented
and
maybe you could even argue that we have
fewer evil leaders
but they're much much less talented as
well now in the case of a talented super
evil leader you don't want the person to
accomplish their evil deeds efficiently
but it is
insane to me that we
have been breaking these conventions um
that are part of our culture
when we are the nuclear we're the
thermonuclear stewards of the planet for
the most part i
i just don't understand us i i look
brian you're catching me in a bad moment
because it is your 50th birthday and i
want to be joyous and positive but
you're asking questions about a world
that makes absolutely no sense and by
the way i would say that
when i started making these style points
um
and you know years later even after i
started making them when i was doing the
edge essays and i was talking about like
you know professional wrestling will
take over the world and all that kind of
stuff or
the original one about um
go virtual young man about my coming to
grips with the blockchain and because it
fell
into my into my line of sight early
those pessimistic
predictions in in some sense that we had
to depart the planet for the electron
layer and that everything was going to
become fake i don't think that that's
that surprising anymore
i
mean
the number of articles that i've read
that have figured out that everything is
professional wrestling you
are unaware that there's any pre-history
of this concept
this is clear look at the cnn numbers
nobody's watching nobody believes nobody
really thinks that a 78 year old
president makes sense we just
we can't figure out anything better to
do and i really
i don't know i mean you can't ask me
about
hope in a in an average sense because i
think there's a lot of things we could
do but we're in no position to do any of
them
yeah i started to review that i'm going
to have uh hopefully biology uh our
mutual friend biology and influence on
the podcast and he's just uh he makes
you
eric look like you know a cheerful pep
squad leader i mean and and i and i
don't say that lightly uh or with any
disrespect to biology uh and i'm
anticipating his appearance here in a
couple of months but um but you know
hearing this retrace and then i have to
you know i'm a contrarian so i'm gonna
push back with respect on you and to
some extent on biology but to say
that uh that this generation doesn't
have
even more potential you know when you
look at our kids we look at our friends
kids when you look at the students that
i'm blessed to teach here when you look
at the technology the increase in power
the things that you can do now i told i
was uh i interviewed our mutual friend
ben shapiro last week and i said ben you
complain every year you come out with a
new book you complain about suppression
of free speech here's your like 10th
book in three years
about the suppression of free speech
what gives and by the way ben you credit
most of the you know kind of aggregating
uh annoyance of technology with the
suppression and i said and we're using
this platform right now i said ben
you've got three million plus followers
on twitter you've got this huge facebook
following youtube following you met your
wife on grind on tinder uh you uh have
an only fan's account and
all right
i gotta go
and uh you know he had to admit that
this was uh that this was true that that
technology we have the power in this
little app and this phone you and i are
tweeting and twittering whatever we're
doing i don't know this is my second
twitter space ever but anyway eric we
have more power than the kings and
queens of uh of queens of new york of no
of uh
of of of the ancient world how can you
be pessimistic this is the greatest time
in human history and we live in the
greatest country in human history why
people this is the weirdest thing is
hang on a second brian could you just
open your mouth
stephen pinker are you in there
um he's coming back on no don't worry
well but
but this is pinker's bizarre i i don't
expect physicists to neglect a potential
term
right so you know famously ballistic
pendulum you shoot a bullet into a
wooden block on a string
block absorbs the bullet
and swings up and in fact uh comes to
rest so where did all where did all the
energy go everything is at rest
temporarily the answer is well you
converted kinetic into potential
so that's what we did we converted our
problems into potential problems of
catastrophic proportions
and of course if you uh if you throw out
potential terms you can get away with
all sorts of things you can get free
energy because uh
hey you don't have you don't have a
conservation law you can get something
for nothing your chicks for free that
that that kind of thing
um
doesn't really appeal to me because it's
it's just a very simple sleight of hand
i i don't even know why we discuss such
things
furthermore wait wait let me just push
back a little bit that power uh i think
you should have jeffrey toobin on your
podcast and uh asked you know what does
it mean that you can broadcast
everywhere to the world you know and
that you can you can meet from people i
actually asked him eric and he said he
doesn't have enough time on his hands
time on his hands
come on that's a quality joke
give it to me brother
no i don't like it it's me i don't know
i really no i'm bringing it up because i
think that in some sense
actually it's one of the things i've i
think i'm sick of me
occasionally i don't mind a zinger if
somebody really really deserves it but
the fact is that the reason everybody
jokes about jeffrey tube and is everyone
knows the danger of having microphones
and video cameras and suffused through
your lives that you don't control and
don't understand at all times
broadcasting to god knows whom
and so much company
let me get to your
your basic point yeah there's a lot to
be thankful for it's been very very
peaceful but uh you know uh
many many take a look farsi you know
the key point is is that uh daniel 5 25
is relevant and
um the writing is on the wall it just
hasn't
it's not evenly distributed in terms of
how to understand it how much of the dye
was cast in the year of my birth i mean
the most monumental things that i'm
aware of in 1971 involved something
really prosaic and and not really known
by too many people and that was the you
know the final decoupling of the dollar
from uh from the gold standard in august
15 1971
i don't remember that but yeah but that
takes three years two years actually to
fully unwind until 1973 so you got to be
very careful because the bitcoin
community
has monopolized the
um discontinuity and i really think that
tyler cowan is probably the tireless
force
that made more people aware of this it
was sort of a cult
uh curiosity that
1970 i used to use 73 and then this
website appeared called wtf happened in
1971
and by tying it to 1971 precisely
they accomplished the
feat of fusing the discontinuity of the
early 70s with bretton woods and
the
uh
the grand finale of the um
decoupling of
our world currencies to convertibility
uh in gold now
i
i'm irritated by that because it's not
their property and
it really has i think to do
um with things that happen upstream from
policy so i really believe that if you
look at all of these crazy graphs
um tyler was right to focus us
uh there were other people who were part
of this cult um and
i tie it
probably to science that science is
upstream of technology technology is
upstream
of uh
innovation and therefore the economy and
i believe it was the fact that science
stopped providing the seed corn for this
whole growth
regime
that um that sort of sowed the scenes of
our own destruction because the key
feature that the u.s that wasn't
understood is an achilles heel
is that it's a very
complicated counter-intuitive
enlightened-based enlightenment-based
culture
and it has to pay a dividend to keep
people interested now i'm happy to be
fascinated by free speech and liberty
and all of these things sort of for
their own sake but i think that's a
minority position it has to pay off in
homes and vacations and it has to pay
off in
in
a sense of the future and i believe that
the future collapsed we don't have a
picture of life after our own demise
that matters to us for the most part now
you do and i do because we have kids
but
imagine you didn't have kids and imagine
that
you didn't necessarily believe in a
bearded dude in the cloud or or an
afterlife
how do you make sure that you get people
to care about the world
beyond their own death and i don't think
we have an answer for that at the moment
this is a point of
serious um discussion with sam harris my
friend who
i believe that he's quite correct that
if we could care about our own death
reliably in its scale
and the world that follows that we could
be ethical people but you can't get most
people
to care about these abstractions unless
it somehow pays off for them so heaven
is a dividend
a second home is a dividend
uh
you know great prospects for your
children is a dividend and
the system stopped paying a dividend and
started revealing itself as having a
pyramidal structure in the absence of
growth
so we're talking with eric weinstein i'm
getting some complaints uh on twitter
that people can't hear you if you could
move the phone a little bit closer to
your mouth uh i know they'll be the
phone of the mic uh the phone now mike
is totally fine you're fine
but if i if you have the phone open i
have the phone in a briefcase yeah it's
gonna cause a feedback loop let's try it
let's do an experiment all right this is
uh this is my one birthday extravaganza
and speaking of my birthday i would be
honored if any of you would give me a
follow on twitter or on uh or on youtube
dr brian keating in both locations i do
interviews with the world's brainiest
and most fascinating folks from
billionaires to nobel prize winners to
both in the case of eric
but later on today we have eric's friend
julian barbour on the podcast talking
about uh his provocative i do not know
julian barbour well he knows you and
that's all that matters and i know of
his work yes i appreciate it so the
janice point will be discussed later on
uh at noon pacific 3 p.m eastern so i do
hope you'll tune in to youtube for that
dr brian keating on every platform that
is available so it's natural to look
back and that's fitting for this uh term
the janna's point when you look back and
you look forward at the same time like
the roman god of you know what janus was
the god of eric
pardon me do you know what janus was the
roman god of
uh deception
no no he was the god of portals
portals
is that right yeah he was a god that
went forward and backwards
simultaneously and he did so in january
that's when january is named after him
because we look back we look forward i'm
always fascinated by origin stories uh
and i want to know actually i've never
asked you what got you interested in
science to begin with what's your
scientific your mathematical origin
story
well um it's a weird question my
father's talked to me about relativistic
effects
and uh i'd never heard of length
contraction time dilation i was a little
kid he used to give me um
legal problems like you know
a guy goes down to the dock to see a
boat called peerless
and
agrees to purchase it for a hundred
thousand dollars thinking it's a steal
and uh it turns out that there's another
boat called peerless for ten thousand
dollars uh this is worth ten thousand
dollars it's a junker of a boat
what should happen given that the two
people had two different models and they
agreed to something so that was the
style of problems that he is an attorney
would give me that was called the good
ship peerless given to him in law school
and then one day he just sort of sprung
on me what do you think happens when
something goes faster
than you can imagine close to the speed
of light
how would you perceive it and he started
telling me these things i couldn't
believe what he was telling me it was
the most romantic
bizarre
the idea that the universe contains such
counter intuition and uh beauty and and
perverse beauty at that
um
i was fascinated by i think the other
thing that really caused me to
sort of go towards science is that
i came to see
most adults
as
saying wildly incorrect things
and
just sort of ubiquitously constantly
incorrect not occasionally they would
screw up
um
and i think that as a kid i started to
believe that more or less
the self-description of the world was so
wildly off that i couldn't even believe
that that was possible so you have to
ask yourself
am i crazy
um
and one great way to check whether
you're crazy is to try to understand
some mathematics some physics some
biology
can can i program a computer so that the
code compiles
and so in certain sense it's also a
check
is my brain
functioning properly and i think that
what i learn is is that
you're not allowed to analyze the world
in which you live without being
considered an uh insane because the
description is so far off
and
was this also not communicated to your
younger brother brett who is also a
scientist who along with his wife
heather hang will be on the into the
impossible podcast thanks to eric being
the shotgun and the [ __ ] making the [ __ ]
up between myself and brett
and we will host them for their new book
which is wonderful i'm reading an
advanced copy called a hunter gatherer's
guide to the 21st century i want to ask
you about that book um i don't know if
you've read it
but
but there's a lot of you in it in a
certain sense that uh the only the
biggest most magisterial kind of
concepts are addressed but in one
passage they say
uh something to the effect they're
talking about a tibetan herdsmen and how
his epigenetics influence uh himself and
that he essentially passes on his genes
uh by by sheer force of will because
there's nothing else for genes to do but
reproduce and i thought that was a
little bit teleological it was
describing this kind of machination or
thought process to what is in in essence
uh not only in the case of dna but
cultural epigenetic manifestations these
are not things that can be really
thought to have purpose what do you make
of that do genes have teleology do they
know what they're doing do they have a
if so how could they possibly know
well not in the standard description
um
you know there's a key question about
is there any kind of a look ahead
function so that anything can have
purpose and i think
you know the way brett
developed it uh
he came up with a term that i quite like
which is perception mediated selection
when you can pres when you're conscious
see there's a there's an old question
about what is consciousness
and one of the theories is the
consciousness is what is
that which can possibly
direct non-smooth muscle to contract is
one of the theories and you know you
think like well that's kind of a weird
weird generating function for something
like consciousness but the point is is
that
directing your body to do things eat
this and not that
um you know make an advance uh
romantically on this person and forego
that person all those sorts of
basic reproduction fighting
um
eating of
evading predators
that may be the sort of the reason for
consciousness and
i think that once you have agency
i'm very fond of pointing out that
intelligent design is actually weirdly
part of darwin
through perception-mediated selection
now people don't like that the idea that
you can choose for example to make
a
mule by crossing a donkey and a horse
and you can choose to breed those lines
independently in order to make more
mules you are intelligently designing
the mule
now the reason that scientists don't
like that is they want to put a
perimeter around the word intelligent
design because they want that term to
result in instant death
now i don't believe that jesus belongs
in discussions of selection and i don't
like
the
religious explanations the young earth
stuff but there are also a lot of
scientists and incidentally who are
religiously motivated to try to figure
out selection paradigms and darwinian
paradigms
to make them work because they don't
feel that the current understanding of
selection particularly the neo darwinian
sort of
synthesis is valid
um
and this issue about how purpose arises
now i'm sort of if i take an atheist
scientific perspective which is that
purpose
grew up in our consciousness or to some
extent in our subconsciousness as an
aide to fitness
so the idea is that that which aids in
fitness is retained
on average
[Music]
that's how i think it goes but somebody
else might say
you're just ignoring how miraculous life
is and the fact that it occurred here
may be a sign of purpose
and i think that there are people with
whom you can have that conversation
who are scientifically honest
and religiously motivated and they're
people with whom you can't have the
conversation who are either
um
crazy from you know they've their jesus
adult uh
and their scripture rattled
or
they are so
um
[Music]
focused on getting rid of religion that
they become irrational and you see that
particularly in some
of the older darwinians
uh who would like to say we tied
everything up with a bow in the early
70s and there's no need to revisit it
because we killed god and uh the deed is
done
that's right there is no god and dawkins
is his prophet
but in well you're
repurposing an old joke about paul dirac
and so i would caution you not to okay i
will say about paul dirac he was not
only the inventor of the anti-particle
but he was sort of the anti-eric in the
sense that uh there was said of dirac
that he would never use two words eric
when none would do he was not very
loquacious as they say um
go ahead you're going to surprise well
first of all i mean the closest analog
to paul do
if we're going to do physics history as
you well know
um was it oppenheimer's letter of
recommendation it said a sec feynman was
a second direct but this time human
the important aspect of paul dirac is
not the quirks of his personality and i
do think that grand farmelo did a
wonderful job
raising the issue of autism and
neurodivergence in the case of paul
dirac but
paul dirac
said quite a lot for a guy who was
supposed to be silent and in particular
i think he is the most courageous
in that he was he and einstein and yang
were all willing to chip away
at the fairy tale we tell about the
scientific method and directs in
particular his 1963 scientific american
article points out
that um a kind of naturality which often
gets called beauty which is confused and
i think
by the string theorists and sabine
hassenfelder has gone into this at great
length but direct's concept of beauty
different from the string theory concept
of beauty is one of robust
co intellectual coherence and that we
should privilege systems that have
robust intellectual coherence because
the agreement with experiment
is highly dependent upon
the instantiation of an abstract idea so
if you choose a slightly different
instantiation you may show zero
agreement with the experiment even
though the basic idea is right
and uh i would say that
i i am not the anti-direct by any means
um nor was firemen he was a pro
dirachist and i'm a pro directorist and
i think that the the superficial aspects
of personality
um
are orders of magnitude less interesting
yeah and when i think about
uh these uh notions as we were talking
about uh origins of life and and of
consciousness just a minute ago i
couldn't help but think of my uh my uh
friend stephen meyer who wrote a book
the god hypothesis
and how it dovetails with something you
said over a year ago now i think on the
portal and you're talking about
schrodinger states in society in culture
you're talking about the reason that we
fight about things like abortion which
is in the news or
ending military conflict or second
amendment etc is because
we can't really handle the quantum
superposition needed to have uh subtle
distinct nuanced discussions
and i was thinking about that in the
context of origin of life because it is
true that there is no explanation
in any cosmological sense of the low
entropy state of the origin of the
universe
there's no
there's no code or something that traces
itself to a low entropy state which is
not in some level organized by some mind
as as stephen points out um and that's
not proof of god you know my as i've
told you in the past my problem with
origin of god origin of life and all
these things is that it always will at
some point i have to agitate for a
personal god
but uh but in the context of of things
like these superposition states another
one that you and i have talked about a
lot is uh the existence of aliens and
unidentified aerial phenomena where it's
it's not clear that one side has the
monopoly on correctness and i wonder you
know how how many of these schrodinger
states can a society handle uh you know
we're getting we've got to cut it out
this is getting absolutely absurd i mean
let me go back to my own
i don't know why i have a an
interpretation of quantum mechanics that
i don't know who to reference it to but
i don't know who
other than me says it this way the weird
thing about quantum mechanics
is that
our quantum theory more generally
is that you get to ask bad questions
uh of a system and the system responds
by giving you answers when it really
shouldn't
and
that's a puzzle to me where
if you say
um
[Music]
of a state you know
are we in a situation where we need
freedom or we need safety
uh
when you're talking about the
coronavirus
um
clearly we both want freedom and safety
and we want to somehow balance them in a
free society
to say you will only accept one or the
other
is madness and
that's what a quantum question is it's
where you're asking
um a superposition
well which are you you know are you
catholic or protestant are
are you uh pro-soviet or against the
soviet there's no idea of anyone saying
i actually really appreciate uh
you know
some aspect of the soviet union and i
really need to test others so this all
or nothing thinking
sort of asking inappropriate questions
of superposition states
and that's what quantum theory does it
gives you artificial answers at random
whereas classical
theory tells you you're asking a
terrible question now questions are
called observables answers are called
eigenvalues and
the answers that are on the multiple
choice portion of the exam are called
eigenstates and you ask a question where
the answer isn't any one of the multiple
choice answers it's some combination of
them and that's not something you can
opt for so i think that in in a weird
way there is a parallel in our society
where we're not allowed
to ask good questions that speak to
quantum
superpositions um
at least their analog in questions of
policy
where do you see us going now let's get
controversial
with science with the role of science as
the replacement
for religion for gods for deities
where do you see us going
where science is is sort of being
politicized not sort of let me just be
bold and say it
uh science is being politicized it's
being used as a as a cudgel and i wonder
you know how if we rely on science you
know carl sagan used to say here i'm
going to bring in my finger pup it's my
birthday i can use as many damn finger
puppets as i want okay there's my finger
puppet man i'm going to give you the
finger carl sagan used to say it's a
real tragedy when a society
has unbridled technology and no
understanding how it works
and uh but i think now now we have you
know kind of almost like we have worship
of science we have uh integrated science
completely technology and uh and we're
sort of worshiping science and so where
do you where do you see that going is
that is that the uh is that the reason
for pessimism about the next 50 years
when we turn 100
i don't even know how to answer this
question
nobody's really
well first of all science isn't in one
state
um
and and i i would like to bring this
sort of to the um 1971 through 73
uh issue that you used to sort of launch
this episode
biology has a million things to do
because the phylogenetic tree uh fanned
out in all different directions and so
you know if you understand something in
fruit flies do you understand it in
zebrafish do you understand the same
thing in c elegans the nematode
or
or in um
you know musespridus or something you
can ask the same question in a bunch of
different times and there's no shortage
of systems so we're nowhere close to
exhausting biology
is it as exciting as the 10 years
between the discovery of the double
helix for dna and its understanding as
the genetic code by marshall nirenberg
a decade later i don't know you can you
can figure that out for yourself is as
exciting as the operon
the pajama experiments i don't think so
but
you can make a good case that things are
plenty interesting and i i wouldn't
disagree with that
math has been preceding a pace um
there have been lots of great things
that have happened
what the heck happened to physics
is the really interesting question
because its behavior
was very different
[Music]
the last person the youngest person i
think to really contribute to the
standard model
turned 70 this year
um so there are no
there are no young women or men who've
contributed to the standard model uh
under the age of 70.
and
that
loss of physics i don't think people
understand how catastrophic it it is
because
physics has passed like thermonuclear
weapons out of the public consciousness
and it's the only phys it's the only
subject
that has really powered the economy um
at the level of growth that we've seen
through semiconductors through
communications and electromagnetic
spectrum what have you
through the world wide web which came
out of cern
when we lose physics
we
lose also hope
and i really think that this goes back
to the alien question let's assume that
aliens are here
um and just stipulate to that for the
moment to explore that branch of the
decision tree because people are
terrified to even say those words
if they are here do we think that they
got here through time dilation
uh
from distant galaxies and that they've
just accepted that the cost of exploring
the cosmos is that you never get to see
anyone again i don't know
most likely not most likely if there
were aliens here and this is something i
think i haven't said fully in public um
they would be here because somebody
somewhere in the galaxy would not only
know about einstein but would know about
a theory that did to einstein what
einstein did to newton which is to
render
you know newtonian physics is a limit of
einsteinian physics now the question is
what is einsteinian physics the limit of
and so when people think about is it
possible to traverse the cosmos they
always say things that are really
very puzzling to me one of which is you
must be talking about faster than light
communication faster than light travel
and i always say well no you're trapped
in an einsteinian paradigm where that's
the only way to do things in your
understanding but
if you have a more complete theory it
may be able to evade the speed limit
like knowing a shortcut
rather than you know zooming around on a
ring road
you know if you can go across the middle
of the road for example
you can show up someplace far faster
than somebody would imagine if you had
to traverse a much longer path
so
i personally think that if you want to
imagine that humans survive
the odds of us surviving on a single
terrestrial surface where every stupid
person has a vote and imagine that you
have an elon musk not of a space program
but somebody who has their own
individual nuclear weapon you know
when you start to democracize
democratize the power
of the nucleus of the of the cell and
and of the atom
it's very dangerous for all of us to be
on the same surface because you could
have a virus escape from from a lab you
could have a nuclear exchange whose
radioactive fallout
you know gives us very few places to
hide
we've got to fan out and if there's an
opportunity to leave
we've got to take it not because this
isn't a great place but because we have
to diversify so that we're not all in
the same experiment i don't want to be
in an experiment with uh
i don't want to be in an experiment with
our current leadership i don't want to
be an experiment with an anti-scientific
world that is depending on science
hating science abusing science
i want to use science so that we can
separate
so that people who have full belief in
you know total freedom or total safety
or
believe that two plus three equals a
chicken or whatever that is that they
believe they need their own planets
they need to explore those ideas on
their own planets and those of us who
basically want to build our families
build our knowledge of the world try to
be decent to each other
be open to markets but recognizing that
they have failures people who want to
lead a more reasonable life
need a divorce
from people who think that you can
continue with
you know like the fourth turning model
oh you know it's a cycle and it always
goes through no it doesn't always go
through this as i've come to say
um
strong men make good times and nuclear
weapons
good times make weak men weak men and
nuclear weapons make end times don't
give me any more of this infinite cycle
nonsense
um
so you know my feeling about this is
aliens are hope
in part
if there were aliens here i would say
that the odds that the einsteinian
theory is merely an effective theory
shoot way the heck up
it means that those singularities of
schwarzschild and the initial
singularity of the cosmological models
are telling us that the theory isn't
complete and that there's probably a way
of evading the speed limit without
breaking it
so that's that's the madness i'm willing
to share with you on your breath when i
think about uh these these notions again
not to bring it too much back to your
brother's new book but he makes a
powerful point that you know the
fundamental element of society is the
campfire and around the campfire tales
would be told and stories would be woven
and non-fiction would be told as well
here's how you catch a rabbit uh here's
how you you know put what kind of cream
to put on a burn uh et cetera et cetera
and no one person the message i take
away interpreting my own way no one
person can have all the information and
that's kind of arguably uh you know
another reason for diversity if one can
use such a term uh and that we need sort
of no since nobody can have it all maybe
the guy who believes
in uh you know in something kooky and
two plus two equals a chicken uh maybe
he or she they think that uh they know
the best way to weave a net to let the
minnows go through uh how do you in
other words how do you know who to uh
what what what's bathwater and what's
baby i i have to say i've gotten
completely bored of this question and
it's not nothing against you but
we are living in a time
that um
that privileges this idea of like no one
person and we're all a community and
we're all getting
so stupid
um
look at the patriot act you know
uh one person opposed the patriot act in
the senate senate that was russ feingold
and i you know it's a community it's
coming to get no stop it russ feingold
was right the rest of you idiots were
wrong it was very clear this was a
degradation of our freedoms one guy has
the ball
period the end there is no more that's
the way i view it very often
and it's nothing against the campfire
and the beauty of kumbaya and all that
stuff
um sometimes things are broadly
distributed sometimes as you know
famously freeman dyson the physicist
needed freeman dyson the mathematician
but the two of them weren't talking to
each other
um even though they both lived inside of
the same brain case first first guest on
the into the impossible podcast freeman
but what i'm trying to get at is um
you don't know what time you're in
and
i haven't read what brett said about the
campfire is not the fundamental unit of
human civilization
um
you know any any anymore do do orca pods
have have campfires it's an abstraction
culture though
sure they have culture
bacteria have culture but i mean there's
culture and there's cultures
again with the dad jokes
you know i think that i i think that the
point is that um
you know
he's he's saying something important but
i don't want to have to comment on
whether the campfire is the fundamental
unit of civilization
i want to ask why are
peter
as mentioning on twitter
our friend peter mccormack he's saying
we should have the creator on
of this website what the f happened in
i don't want to have another bitcoin
conversation i love peter
but
seriously
you don't get to repurpose the
1970s
thing as just some simplistic thing
about bretton woods bitcoin and real
money and austrian economics
and and i'm also sort of sick of this
whole cyber hornet phenomena where
anybody who dares say anything against
bitcoin you know
there's also a harassment issue in that
community and there's a giraffe yeah
okay
i don't but again you talked to brett
about the campfire talked to peter
mccormick about 1971 and bretton woods i
personally think that this is completely
misguided the danger
it's like what black lives matter did to
everybody's frustration it took
everybody's frustration and said it's
all about george floyd and the bitcoin
people said the early 1970s is all about
bretton woods which it isn't right and
nothing it's not all about the campfire
this goes back to the issue of
these are simplistic perspectives where
we've got to pull back
and
you know
physics needs
to restart our economy and get us off
the planet
and
there's all these ideas that we're going
to become wise or our money is going to
solve everything bitcoin fixes this
bitcoin fixes everything
no
we need to separate we need distance
from each other some of us are so
dangerously confused and think about
somebody who like for example doesn't
accept physics and doesn't accept the
law of the excluded middle because they
came through some critical theory
department that tells you everything is
relative
that person is broadcasting their
message
through code that they do not understand
and could not actually do themselves
using their theories using zeros ones
the electromagnetic spectrum
engineering talents
all sorts of things that they reject and
then we build this entire thing for them
to broadcast hey you know that's just
your opinion man
it's just like
i
you need your own planet you get a
planet and you get a planet and you get
a planet and i don't want to be on any
of your planets i want to be on planets
with sensible people
one of my kids likes to play a game
called solar smash where you
literally nuke different planets with
high-powered lasers from some vantage
point in space um
why are so many economics professors
poor
uh i want to get to elon musk in here
and his retweeting or liking you uh etc
and and by the way uh i i wonder you
know i heard yesterday you know some
famous guy this guy chris ruffo i think
he he got unverified from twitter and i
was like well that's that's you know
like
look we've all accepted that all of our
conversations are adulterated right like
if
if you look at
kraft singles
and it says american cheese product or
something like that um
why
you know and you're surprised that that
there's some weird ingredients in there
it's not just coming out straight out of
a cow
um
yeah i don't
ask the question again
why are so many professors of economics
poor
um
first of all economics basically splits
into two categories there are people who
are vying for power and there are people
who are trying to do sort of technical
work um
and in general i don't find them to be
the same people
so the micro economists in general are
not trying to get to jackson hole and
you know conferences to figure out how
the fed should steer things what not
um
i i think that the basic problem is that
it appeals to a
very rigid mind so if you build
everything around homo economicus which
is what we did historically which is
this model that clearly doesn't
represent how human beings actually are
in the world you tend to select for very
rigid thinkers who have a particular
penchant
for finding surprising things that
people lies that people tell themselves
and each other so famously a
professor of economics who we're
familiar with
suggested that no one should give gifts
because it's much more efficient to give
cash
um and that's what economists have
historically like to do they they have
this idea that relentlessly and
unflinchingly they apply
um
tools of utility maximization this is
sort of a definition due to gary becker
finite constraints and they try to turn
humans into robots and make the robots
maximally efficient and if that's what
appeals to you
it's very likely that you're
not going to be
very effective in
in amassing wealth i mean particularly
if you're doing
global macro trading global macro is a
very strange thing if you have real
macro economists because you can invest
in macro instruments
why would any
true
macro economist need to pester the
government for taxpayer dollars if they
had theories about the future that gave
them an understanding of the world they
should be able to speculate their way
into wealth and turns out to be much
harder so it's weirdly adversely
selected for people
who claim that they can understand
macroeconomics but in fact
through their applications for grants
reveal that they don't know how to
predict the future
so now my follow-up you walked right
into my trap
sprung on you my birthday present for
today uh talking to eric weinstein
proprietor of the portal podcast other
plosive
things that you can find on the world
wide web
contained within walled gardens such as
throttled accounts and so forth and
verified blue check marks etc etc but
you can get me a birthday present you
can subscribe to my uh youtube channel
dr brian keating i'm talking with dr
julian barbour later on today at noon
and i have conversations with michael
saylor and peter schiff and i also have
nine nobel prize winners soon to be 10
and maybe even 11 or 12 uh for my new
book think like a nobel prize winner
comes out in two weeks can pre-order
everywhere books are to be pre-ordered
uh but eric uh the reason i brought up
economic what makes you think that
physics professors are any different in
other words why are they broke so to
speak uh in the sense that not a whole
lot of them you know what i a trust to
watch my kids or b trust to fix my my
1979 volkswagen rabbit
come on
if you gave
physicists money and autonomy and you
let them get back to their actual
culture
wouldn't you trust them a whole lot more
than you do right now
and i think this is the thing that's
really really irritating
why
if you ask do i do i trust the nih do i
trust the cdc do i trust
my government
well the answer of course right now is
no
but it's very leadership dependent
and i don't trust physicists right now
because physicists
are induced to lie in order to survive
and whenever you tell somebody hey we're
going to put you under total
transparency we're going to starve you
for resources we're going to make you
reapply re-justify yourself constantly
what is somebody supposed to say hey the
field hasn't moved in 50 years it's
incredibly hard i want to
diverge from the
what are thought to be the smartest
people in the world and what they
believe because i think they're all
crazy
that's what you have to do to be a
physicist now and function in theory
and so in general um i would trust very
very wealthy physicists in in theory in
particular and there just aren't very
many of them and the reason is because
physics like music is a fatal attraction
why
the theory i mean obviously i'm battling
the upton sinclair urge to advocate for
something on home on which my paycheck
depends i'm an experimental physicist
and to be an experimental physicist one
needs to know an awful lot of theory
just not have the ability to do theory
but we've revolutionized the universe in
a practical sense all the things you
mentioned from uh the transistor
uh the laser they got telecommunications
those all came from experiment in fact
some of them came from particle physics
or radio astronomy so great so let's
talk about the experiment that you want
to do that revolutionizes
i have nothing against experiment
leading theory but you have to
appreciate
sabina is quite correct about some
things and wrong about others for
example
she's quite correct that the current
crop of
physicists is widely
uh suffused with crazy ideas that have
been very destructive of the culture of
theoretical physics
on the other hand i don't see the
experiment that somebody's itching to do
on a tabletop that is likely
i mean
to change everything so if there is a
precision experiment we don't always
have to go higher on higher energies we
can go to higher and higher precision or
we can do something super clever that
nobody thought to do
but i don't see the the great puzzle of
where we are in physics right now is
that the system almost closes
prematurely
right and so with the higgs field
it but for dark energy and dark matter
you could make an argument maybe this is
all there is
maybe there isn't anything more than
three generations of fermions and a
bunch of bosons and it's kind of a mess
and it's kind of beautiful and that's
what it is and why do you think there's
more to be had
that is the great danger about what
befell us and to be blunt i don't think
you guys have the money the skills
the energy levels or the precision or
the idea about what experiment to do
unless like let's say this muon
anomaly turns out to be right or
something like it
um to lead us out of this valley and in
particular i'm not scared by
experimentalists
trying to do theory as well i would like
to see more unified minds that aren't
either soldering something in a tunnel
in switzerland
um
or
or to or at a whiteboard i'd like to see
him he's just doing both but i think
it's a little bit oversimplified i mean
again all the things you're talking
about getting off the planet
uh you know verner von braun didn't look
into the rocket equation and newton and
oh let me devise or goddard 100 you know
80 30 years earlier these are these are
tinkers these are innovators these are
inventors these are explorers an
experiment and i i know you didn't come
to you know have a battle royale about
the you know coke versus pepsi
experiment versus theory i think a
healthy environment has both and some of
the best physicists you've already
mentioned
that's not what we're doing
what i'm trying to say is is much more
repugnant and horrible and awful than
that which is
where
are we going to find the feynmans
the rocks the einsteins and the yangs
and
okay you have great experimentalists
but the power of the human mind
to think this thing through
nothing more than a white board
it's it's incredibly unfortunate that we
have a group of greying physicists
almost no you know look under 70
nobody's made contact
from fundamental theory
um
with experiment essentially for
that's an insane situation so it's very
hard for me to continue to point and say
hey the system really works but you know
what the system really works the problem
is the transparency nobody wants to say
this
where who's got a slush fund
we need slush funds where you can just
dip into a drawer and say yeah i'm
paying you for three years well why
should elon do that or jim simons why
should it be the government why don't we
have you know more agitation on behalf
of the lipstick equivalent of our budget
going to nasa and you know how many
dancing videos on tick tock and one half
so sorry i'm not sure what the question
should our government be doing i think
the government's the only
yeah of course you're saying where there
is no you know man uh step in and
the government
the government is in a contract that
it's welching up
right and the idea that it is not a
signed contract where we didn't go to a
lawyer and say hey i love you so much
let's get a lawyer and paper the prenup
so that we can we can get it on
this is craziness we had an agreement
the government welched
and we're not allowed to patent things
you know like for example
i thought about the fact that
many of my academic colleagues think
nothing of the idea that they should be
able to put anybody's name on whatever
it is that they
so you do the work somebody else's name
hey it's just the matthew effect it's
just the matilda effect it's nothing
personal oh you know
nobody you can't work on your own theory
well science progresses funeral by
funeral we've got all of these ways of
executing the fact that the system fell
apart
we call it the matthew effect the
matilda effect and funeral by funeral
for example
we discourage people at every possible
stage extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof
correlation does not imply causation
all of our thinking
that is meant to keep us honest and safe
so that we don't
think you know that we've achieved
something like we haven't as in string
theory
that kind of thinking
has now been repurposed to try to
terrify anybody from moving and from
[Music]
doing things imagine that derock told
you that
he'd taken a square root of the klein
gordon equation and that the only thing
is is that the numerical coefficients uh
weirdly anti-commuted so he was looking
for numbers like seven and three where
three times seven was equal to negative
seven times three and you'd say well
that's stupid
right then you don't realize oh they're
matrices not numbers and in
in two years or three months or
four hours he's going to realize it's
matrices
well now what we're doing is we're
shutting everyone down we're making
everybody talk about their work we're
taking people's names off of their own
work handing it to somebody else we're
making them apply for grants repeatedly
we're scrutinizing each other's stuff
it's just so dumb
we need a culture where we're in control
of our own ship and everyone else can
get the hell out and we we know how to
make that work that's why you have
leaders of the field like an oppenheimer
and
sometimes those leaders would you know
disagree with each other as as teller
and oppenheimer did let's say okay
but effectively we need the bureaucrats
the hell out of our subject we need the
educators out of our subjects we need
lower level people who tend to think
about everything in cut and dry terms
out of the subjects we need to
reinvigorate these subjects with
imagination with resources
and of course it should be the
government and of course they should
either
honor their
understanding of the agreement or let us
patent the semiconductor the world wide
web the electromagnetic spectrum
and and we'll just charge them a royalty
and we'll fund it that way and
physicists will be flying around in
their gulf streams and everybody else
can be on a greyhound bus however you
want to do it and then they'll have
portraits hanging in their offices in
their thousand dollar eames chairs and
then it'll all get taken away and we
won't have toys to play with well that's
a reference to the s
ssc where
we
angered certain members of congress in
particular sherwin bullard i believe
by
physicists saying we want nice things in
our offices we want to be part of the
world that we're powering and i used to
i've changed my mind on that i used to
think physicists were arrogant pricks
who wanted to put portraits in their
office and pretend that they were titans
of industry or something like that my
new view is they're arrogant pricks who
deserve to put portraits in their
offices
because someone has to and when on us uh
no i i mean i agree there should be
prestige but as i said i think we have
an awful lot of prestige some earned
some not and i think that you know there
is sort of an overestimate uh in your
opinion of you know what the both on the
negative and on the positive you know
how dire the situation i think we have
incredibly inventive young physicist in
both theory and experiment and i think
uh there is certainly a lack of funding
and resources but then again you get
people like your friend elon i know he's
not your friend but uh you did tweet
with him never spoken with i'm sure you
could arrange that in about 20 minutes
but i don't think so i think he may want
to avoid it and i want to be sure
that if he wants to there's no reason to
avoid it right like he's a physics guy
yeah he wants to get off this planet to
your alma mater
pardon me he was a physicist at your
alma mater true
but my point is for whatever reason he
knows i'm out here he's like my tweets
we've interacted slightly on on twitter
people don't
understand that
when somebody doesn't want to do
something you don't know why he doesn't
want to do something i don't want to put
him in a bad spot of course do i
disagree with the way in which he's he's
allocated his portfolio of options on
how to get off the planet
i don't understand it
i really really i'm nothing confuses me
more than why elon hasn't bet on physics
and why he's betting on rockets on the
other hand
what do i know i mean maybe it's an
arrangement with the government that i
can't see maybe it's this maybe it's
that maybe he doesn't want to talk for a
good reason
i'm not going to have a nonsense
conversation with him where i just talk
about rockets and occupy mars if i talk
to him i would want to talk to him and
it could be privately about
tell me how you see i want to listen
more than i want to speak
how do you see
the crisis in theoretical physics and
why are you so unmotivated to get
involved
i mean you saw what happened uh just
over the summer with uh people claiming
that perhaps the aliens visiting us are
just bored billionaires from another uh
space faring civilization i can't take
these conversations anymore this is just
it's like
we've learned
i think it was wonder around the time i
saw people saying number go up
or orange man bad right or but those
mean tweets
it's like this is not
i don't even understand what no i'm just
saying where is the upside for him he's
got you know people criticizing bernie
sanders robert reich my colleague up at
uc berkeley you know his wealth
increased by by the way how can an
economist a professor of economy who was
like with their treasury secretaries how
can he know that his he didn't get like
six billion dollars worth of cash you
know because tesla went up it's it's the
stock went up or bezos there are the
vilification of these people who are
putting it all betting
maybe they're doing it your way why are
you and i discussing
robert reich i just don't understand
this like okay some old guy from the
clinton administration who the hell
cares
and you know the thing you know glenn
greenwald was just talking about cnn's
numbers have plummeted there's some
point at which we just have to say
why do we even talk to the people who
constantly
are
jealous
um
why do we talk to people who are
maximally confused okay so we can find
some professor somewhere
who tells us that the rules of
arithmetic are the pros the product of
uh you know scottish imperialism
whatever
that person needs their own room their
own conference they need to just go away
from people who are trying to get work
done
and we can't keep
wasting our time because robert reich is
confused about the money supply and how
stock markets fluctuate
you know is he there when he says wow
you know
i hope i hope you guys are having a
better day than elon he lost four
billion dollars today
well yes the stock is swinging around
but like look at look at monetary
aggregates m1 through m3
when you print more dollars when you
when you create more money um every
equity is
priced as an exchange rate right it's an
exchange between the equity and the fiat
currency that
functions as the numerator the unit of
account
so
if you print a ton of money what are you
what are you doing to that exchange rate
you're you're devaluing and diluting the
holders of the dollar
and you're privileging
those who hold equities and this is what
the bitcoin people get right you know
which is
hey it's a bet against the competency of
our system
we bet that the federal reserve and
central bankers are going to have to
print their way out of a system that
makes no sense and when they do
we're going to have a token that we
don't see as being um
printable easily so there'll be 21
million tokens
in all and we'll just count on the fact
that you have to print in order to lie
and that's what we're doing so you know
yes but
i don't want to talk i don't here's the
thing brian
i want to spend our time differently so
we're both over 50.
let's try not to have the crazy people
drive our conversation the bitter people
the unethical people
um
we need to actually drive our own
conversations and we need to stop
talking to them
yes and and engaging with them and
that's where the you know walled garden
effect comes into play with the honey
trap of uh followers subscribers likes
and and so i don't blame anybody for
engaging this it's all good fun and here
i am chilling for people to subscribe to
my youtube channel on my birthday which
happens once a year uh but this is a
feels like a momentous one 50 years old
for some reason i don't know why maybe
it's the shiny new red corvette i just
got uh no i didn't do that but um
but uh i think about you know kind of
big picture things obviously it's it's
natural to do so at this time in life
and for me you know the the kind of
looking forward i guess i don't have the
same panic that you do and maybe i'm
just not aware i mean i like to think
i'm pretty uh aware of what may happen
in the future i've been uh i've been
fairly successful in life in terms of
you know career and so forth but i look
at
thinking locally like i asked you this
i'm never going to ask you again because
you know the answer to it but if i ask a
normal person eric not someone of your
uh of your particular caliber i said
what's your name of your great
grandfather four times over on your
mother's side nobody in the hell knows
who the hell that they might not even
know who their you know grandparents
father was but you know it so i'm not
going to ask you you already told me uh
but the point being uh maybe we get
grandkids if we're lucky and by the way
a shout out to melanie knocking our
mutual friend you know she proves you
you don't need actual biological kids i
don't mean that but our memes are not
our memes but our but our actual uh our
values we can teleport those right now
or establish the teleportation mechanism
to the future
and what the hell is wrong with that you
know in other words having ideological
errors biological errors if you can if
you can't ideological layers um this is
the only method of time travel that we
know about and i just wonder you know
because i worry about you uh you know
how how much of a crisis is this this
getting off the planet because i i
actually
am i'm quite sanguine about it and and
perhaps for no other reason then
about what i'm saying about humanity's
future i know it i'm not stephen pinker
he and i fought about this as well he's
not in my office
although
although he will hopefully come back in
a couple weeks on the or his new book
about rationality looking forward to
that uh but uh but because i think he
ignores something deeper he ignores the
fact that the reason that things get
better is because they stand on the
shoulders of giants that came before and
those could be scientists those could be
you know moral thinkers philosophers
theologians whatever
and for me um the access to tech i'm not
a kurzweil i don't believe the
singularity is real i don't have any
vitamins to hawk uh like he does uh but
nevertheless if you look at uh the pace
of change and just the adaptability that
my you know three-year-old
can when you know when she's talking to
me try to scroll my face you know she
she's used to interrupting she tries to
like you know when i'm boring her like
i'm boring many people right now she'll
try to scroll my face like she's grown
up as a techno you know as a digital
native um but what can that unlock and
and when we have really robust things um
not just looking at how negative it
could destroy uh you know certain
interactions certain cultures etc but
what is the power if if i'd asked you by
the way in
1996 you know when the internet was just
coming along you probably sent your
first email in
1989 1990. you know would you have been
an author would it would have young eric
been an optimist back then you know 30
year old eric i'm
well let me
take that
it's not a fair question
if if i've
more or less look
i've done some cool stuff
i haven't done anything
as cool as geometric unity
i've put my
my best shot taking one shot on goal and
people ask like what happens if it's
just wrong
and the first thing is
do you know how few people get to take
one shot on goal
almost no one
has ever tried to take a shot on goal
garrett lisey is a guy who actually
and i always have to say it i think he's
completely wrong but he actually has a
shot on goal
and i just think it was wide you know
[Music]
in order for garrett to do what he did
he has to be incredibly optimistic
and i really appreciate that about him
and you know people say oh he didn't do
this and he forgot that and there's a
signer and blah blah blah okay whatever
he's the man in the arena the man in the
arena said i think that there are three
generations of matter because of
triality and there's triality implicit
in spin eight and spin aid is inside of
spin semi spin 16 twice over inside of
e8 that's where triality comes from and
then you say what about bosons and
fermions he says well that's
you have you have chirality because you
have vile spinners attached to semi-spin
16 so you have 128 dimensional
representation not 256. he's got an
answer at a phenomenological level for a
bunch of different stuff
i view him as incredibly optimistic
now
why
am i pessimistic if i'm trying to do
something like that
in order to save us
is shackleton an optimist or a pessimist
brian
i think he's an optimist okay so that's
my point so let's [ __ ] get the show
on the road let's let's actually fund
some stuff and it's more important
people
misunderstand this
it's not worth doing physics for example
unless there's a functioning community
and by a functioning community i don't
mean a bunch of people who
can you know technically go through
something i mean you actually have to
have ideas you're talking about ideas
i am super optimistic that we can get
off this planet not that i know that to
be the case but if we can do to einstein
what einstein did to newton we have a
hope
and we're not excited
like nobody's excited
and i'm excited
i just don't have the same
perspective that we have to get off this
planet
look what what happened today let me ask
you a column was that because there is a
counter factual aspect to what you're
saying
and i have a factual aspect what do you
think would happen the day after we
discover
whatever life form you want from uh
from bacteria to bach
from uh rocks to rachmaninoff from a
kardashev scale to the kardashian scam
take your pick what do you have what
happens the next day
and beware i have a counter i have a
factual not a counterpart i have a fact
what happens the next day to humanity's
vision of of the universe and every
place like form that isn't carbon based
whatever it could be carbon could be it
could be dolphins on jupiter not from
these parts right something doesn't
share a genetic code proven gen uh
definitely peer reviewed as you love to
do you you don't accept uh you know the
newspaper unless it's been peer reviewed
i i understand
peer review peer review that's what kept
the academic enterprise peer review has
been there since the beginning of
science i think it was invented by
aristotle
you know aristotle speaking of dolphins
all right go ahead okay next day the day
after the day after great movie we're
gonna get bored
i was there for the moon landing i saw
the first moon landings one of my
earliest memories
the thing that we don't talk about is
how bored we were when we left
actually we discovered aliens and we we
have and they have never been refuted
and they were published in a
peer-reviewed journal there was a news
conference by bill clinton on the white
house alone you can see it in the movie
contact
and that is the discovery of microbial
respiratory products from the allen land
hills meteorites found in antarctica
where i maintain my my winter home
and that discovery was never refuted has
never been refuted um upcoming guest
sarah rugheimer is talking about this
what what do we think is going to be
different i've heard it said by people
like lee cronin and others who's a guest
also sarah walker that once we discover
life it's going to revolutionize i say
go down to the pacific ocean you know go
down to santa monica scoop up some some
water you're going to find trillions of
life forms we exterminated so many
species on earth let alone humans on
earth you're always paying attention
nobody cares nobody cares right we're
dead so why do you care so much about
getting off this pla why do you think
that's going to be the key that i want
about 1971 brian let's get back to my
birthday okay
what music came out in 1971
um i got in a birthday card from my
friend dave um
uh
uh my love is alive by the gary parsons
project i don't know tell me my friend
joni mitchell's blue came out
one rolling stone sticky fingers
a little thing called led zeppelin iv
right
so think about hey mama say the way you
move
gonna make you sweat
get the guitar come on you gotta play me
a happy birthday rum's on that one
bonham's drums are completely i don't
know what time he's in but it's crazy
type we didn't know about stairway to
heaven until 1971 that's right okay
and you know bowie was thinking about
changes we care about so much that was
happening around that time
we were vibrant we were alive we care in
some sense more about that time than we
care about our own time because we were
alive in a different way
and
you know it's very hard to imagine
[Music]
how different things were that was the
year that a
physicist
organized a break-in
to the
fbi offices in media pennsylvania and
told us
effectively to look up the word co-intel
pro revealing an entire dirty tricks
campaign of our intelligence community
against american citizens
um
physicists from haverford
we were totally alive in a way that we
are not totally alive now
the possibilities
uh of what could be
i don't think
um you know we just been to the moon we
didn't know what we would do next
i think that when we actually have the
ability to explore the galaxies and to
understand our context there will be a
shift in human understanding of
ourselves
and i do think that when we actually
have discussions with something that was
not built around these parts
um it will be humbling i i have viewed
us as north sentinel island we
may very well be under control
of something like india and i worry a
lot about north sentinel island and
whether or not they have a fermi paradox
like hey where is everybody
um nobody's allowed to land on north
sentinel island without permission of
the indian government and they don't go
there anymore
so whatever it is that um
that's going to happen
it's going to be big and then we're
going to have the weird captain cook
phenomena you have to remember that
captain cook showed up in hawaii they
thought he was god they gave him an
unbelievable time with feasts and
revelry and pageantry and then he had
such a good time that he came back a
short time later and they said wait
you're here again and they killed him
um
god on his second
trip through because he was taking way
too much of the locals good stuff
we can get bored of absolutely anything
now what i'm trying to suggest is
try to imagine that you're not thinking
about going to the grand canyon or
cappadocia
or um you know seeing angel falls on the
tapues or something like that but you're
actually thinking about billions of
different death destinations with
a world that is so
unimaginably rich that you're just
excited that uh
that it's not the world being your
oyster but
the universe or you know in my hopes the
observers
that
i think that's where i am i've gotten to
the point where i don't want to have
earthbound conversations anymore i'm so
completely confused why do we
why do we rat hole to use the software
term uh
on the same issues day in and day out
they progress not at all
we just learn to distrust each other and
hate each other we're jealous of each
other
i i i've called this i've started to
call this the degraded state
where when you respond to a friend with
lol
or you know
right no
there's like no verbs or anything we're
just sort of grunting at each other over
the internet angry that other people
seem to be having a better time than we
are we're not doing the work we need to
be doing
more or less private enterprise is the
only thing that's still really working
at the moment and it's not like
government is working it's not like
science
is is working the way i want it to
um
what what i see over and over again is
is that the the part of the world that's
still working is private enterprise and
we may lose that too
i i i think that i'm actually wildly
more optimistic than you are and i don't
mean to be mean on your birthday
but
the thing that i find that you do that's
most optimistic is that you're willing
to risk
for changing things
you know you're willing to talk about
stephen meyer on a science podcast when
i know that some number of your
colleagues will just say
oh wow
good to know bye-bye um
you know if anybody says anything like
intelligent design and i know you don't
you're not an anti-scientific person
we've got to save this and i really
think that people like you and me
are
not doing enough in terms of trying to
lead because we don't
even the concept of leadership is
somehow tied to hitler anybody who tries
to lead
you'll see terry saying oh wow it's van
gaal he's just trying to put money in
his own pocket authoritarian
ego tortance
i'm optimistic that we can do something
and i'm pessimistic that we will do
something i think that there's plenty to
do
where
nobody
let me say something else about silicon
valley
i'm very concerned that my friend mark
andreessen is quite correct
about software eating the world
what i think that silicon valley
didn't understand
is that what we did is we hoovered up a
bunch of people who have technical jobs
we brought them away from the command
line so they're not actually coding they
call them technologists
they make fabulous amounts of money
learning that everything that you build
that is of an institutional character
can be disintermediate disintermediated
with a program
that set us up
to lock up all of the best minds
not all of them let me speak hyperbolic
many of the best minds
with much of the world's wealth
eager to solve problems afraid to build
or invest in anything
because god forbid what if somebody took
money and and used it to check into the
four seasons
uh and went to a day spa and uh and hung
out by the pool you know oh my god that
would be wasting taxpayer money or or or
you know
somebody's like trying to have a good
time we need
roughly speaking
to make sure that our scientific
community
has institutions and are insulated that
what is the purpose of billions of
dollars if not fu money i don't grasp
this
i don't believe in redistribution of
wealth i do believe in a redistribution
of fu
the people who need to say fu need the
resources and the insulation to say fu
and that's how we learn how to trust i
had a tweet the other day about you can
either have scientists you can have
scientists you can control and you can
have scientists you can trust and i very
carefully said
choose up to one you can have science
scientists that you neither control or
trust i'm not disputing that
but if you control your scientists then
you fundamentally cannot trust them
that's right and we need to risk
scientists
who are capable
of saying no because they're insulated
and if you don't insulate scientists
from the market
you will not get a functioning
uh
china is going to figure this out at the
same time that we're
we're
fetishizing diversity inclusion and
equity
and they're going to leap ahead of us
where they're going to do what the
soviets did like the soviets had
crazy sharyashika prisons where you put
very smart people in country club
prisons and told them to do work
and the prisons were relatively nice
this is where leon theremin for example
developed the ability to use a window
pane as a microphone so that they could
listen in on the u.s embassy by watching
the vibrations
you know those sorts of things
china's going to have to experiment with
freedom and what we're going to do is
we're going to experiment with shackling
people with loyaltyo's forcing them to
repeat things that make no sense because
they want to be seen as good people and
they don't want doors slammed in their
face if they want grants renewed
and i think it's incredibly imperative
that
either the government or private wealth
or a bank heist or something
is used to insulate the scientists who
we depend on to know
what's going on with this virus
what is going on
with the physical prospects for going
beyond einstein can you please stop
lying to me about string theory and tell
me where we actually are
you know you've seen this on your
program every time you ask a string
theorist well you know what's the most
important thing in the world geez we've
got the theory of everything
it's called string theory i want this
tattooed on my forehead and i want it on
my headstone
come on well i have a new phrase now
eric that string theory is perhaps the
most important theory ever devised for
describing string theory
we have it's been inordinately
successful and before i conclude i know
you've been so generous and it's my
birthday i shouldn't keep you tarrying
you um i want to ask about kayfabe
because i have no other idea what the
hell that is let alone what the hell
happened in 1971 the year i was born
reminding you we're talking eric
weinstein proprietor of the portal
podcast people are begging clamoring for
the portal of return including a special
episode with yours truly which will be
one for the vaults i'm sure
i urge you to follow me on twitter and
on youtube where i am dr brian keating
in just about an hour and a half my
interview with julian barbour who's
another out of the box thinker uh we'll
be honest i want to talk about cafe but
i want to get your reaction to this
quote uh by one
mathematician
david hilbert
who once said that we can measure the
importance of scientific work by the
number of earlier publications rendered
superfluous by it do you agree with that
statement
i i have some qualms with it
i don't know this big simple stuff
yeah it's always very profound you know
it's like it's like when people quote
feynman to you you know yeah if you
can't explain it to your grandmother
then you do not understand it then he
gets the nobel prize and said can you
please explain it if i can explain it it
wouldn't be worth it it would be worth a
freaking prize right and we always quote
the one that gives us that feeling of
superiority over our fellow man we don't
quote the one that actually makes it
real right um
no the k-fave has to do with the fact
that we have to lie about what we're
doing all the time so for example when i
was at harvard in the math department
i read a grant um
and maybe i don't mind telling the story
because the the individual is deceased
and i think i've spoken reverend
reverently about him but i went up to
the great raul bot who gave us bot
periodicity and i said i was reading
your grant
about what you were doing in low
dimensions and it said that
your work in low dimensions is important
because it might elucidate not theory
and not theory is extremely important
for plasmids
and understanding
plasmids in biology
he said what's a plasmid
i said it's your grant sir
we had not written it
someone
had taken the grant that he had written
and put in that it was very important
for him to do low dimensional topology
so that we could study looped
nucleic acid
that might be knotted and therefore
invigorate the pharmaceutical industry
something completely crazy like that
that's cafe
where the system is lying
in order for the system to continue
he wasn't doing anything to elucidate
anything about plasmids
what we have is that we have to now tell
untruths at an almost continuous
rate
in order to keep our jobs in order to
not run afoul of twitter or youtube or
anything like this i mean when you
talked about somebody losing a blue
check mark or somebody being taken out
nobody anymore believes that twitter
doesn't shadow ben i mean i can tell
instantly that a tweet of mine um is
being throttled because i have a very
good idea after over a decade of how how
much reach a tweet will have and if i
throw red meat at somebody i always get
clicks on those things unless it's
throttled
we don't believe in anything we don't
believe in cnn we don't believe in our
political parties our slogans you know
trust in the press is that an all-time
low viewership is way off
in order to actually rebuild trust in
society we've got to start excluding
people and those people very often
look like brian stetler they look like
joe biden we need to exclude mitch
mcconnell and donald trump and nancy
pelosi
these people really can't be at our
table and we've also got to take
it up that
um you know in science
i don't like picking on people but
somebody just came out with a book where
they were going on and on about
um
you know how string theory is the theory
of everything the god equation i didn't
say it you said it he's a guest on the
show we've we fought about that
yeah we can take it but it's
it's not interpersonal it's like why do
you guys put up
with these giant programs that are
clearly completely wrong
and
you're very afraid of individuals like a
joe rogan coming to a conclusion and
speaking but you have an enormous
program that's known to be wrong by the
way
check out the eco health alliance
you know this is what
fauci was funding the wuhan lab through
i don't think i looked at the number of
views on their videos the number of
views on their videos are minuscule
nobody is watching what this thing is
we we're not engaged we're having these
conversations that are incredibly
repetitive people don't have new ideas
if people have new ideas they're treated
uh
you know like like the end of
coleridge's kubla khan so you know
uh we leave a circle around him thrice
and close your eyes and unholy dread for
he hun honeydew hath fed and drunk the
milk of paradise everybody who actually
has an idea is treated like a crazy
person
and
we've overdone
particularly from my side of the aisle
the left of center
notion of sophistication
is that we're trying to hobble everyone
who would step into the arena and say i
have a new idea about how to do
something
really important
and
i i think that that's what's depressing
is is that we're making life horrible
for everyone who's trying and we're
making life very easily easy for people
who are attached to institutions whether
it's facebook or google or twitter or
the democratic party harvard princeton
or the institutions like the urban
institute we've got to reverse that it's
very important that individuals who can
still think and still speak
start to shoulder more of the
responsibility for getting us out of the
rut and i think that that's what i'm
super optimistic about and by the way
brian you've got five kids right
what bothers me the most
is watching the two generations in front
of me clearly not care about their kids
and their kids kids
it's evident in how they speak i don't
understand it
i want a better world for the future and
i want to be
you know open and transparent that
there's not likely to be 300 years of
future
if we don't panic and start trying to
say are we really going to try to upload
into silicon are we really going to try
to get wise so that there are no more
wars ever with new technology are we are
we really going to try to get off this
planet with rockets
at what point do we get serious and say
we need a portfolio of solutions to
escape our coming fate and we need the
people who are attracted to those to
participate in society and we need to
stop looking at everything they do
scrutinize them make them constantly
apply
for increasing
for resources citing all of their
progress we know how to do science and
it's time we get back to doing science
and kick the administrators
the people who think we can't do the
people who believe that somehow science
has nothing to do with national interest
it's time to exclude all sorts of voices
because we're in an emergency situation
we've got to restart growth and more
importantly we've got to diversify so
that different people can can run
different experiments and we're not in
just one giant petri dish the way we
found out we are with covet
uh eric
um
just taking a swig of my simon's
observatory whiskey brand um some of the
finest whiskey notes i know you have a
bottle i believe you have a bottle um
last question i want to do a little
torah learning a little actually brian
yes it's your birthday i'd like to ask a
question okay go for it
brian
i think you're exactly right that we've
neglected experimental physics what
should we be super excited about that's
coming down the pike in experiment how
can we be using the the universe as our
accelerator if we can't necessarily
build machines what are some of the
precision experiments we don't know to
ask about
and can you just please excite us on the
theory side of the equation with some of
the coolest things that you think are
happening currently in experiment well
i'm obviously biased but i'm biased for
a reason that i love the biggest
questions since i was a kid a wee lad i
only wanted to answer the biggest i was
very obsessed with death as a kid and
actually i didn't think i would reach
the age of 50 uh maybe even let alone uh
even younger ages and now i'm here i'm
like wow i got uh i'm kind of on parole
with the with the second half maybe this
is the
thank you i'm rounding rounding second
base maybe with some life extension uh
that i might be able to enjoy by by just
lasting long enough you know as they say
most of life is just showing up so uh
when i think about what excites me the
most it's always been answering this
fundamental question i want to know if i
can not prove god exists but falsify
god existence if that's even possible so
i am an israeli i am an israeli not by
cut nationality but by
virtue of the word israel which you know
in hebrew means to struggle to wrestle
and it really i have to tell you it
tickles me and saddens me when i talk to
one of the second most prominent atheist
on earth lawrence krauss and he doesn't
know what the word israel means and he
doesn't know and he doesn't know
anything about judaism whatsoever he
just knows he's not it okay fine anyway
the word israel in hebrew the language
of judaism means to wrestle or fight
against god so i told him i said larry
lawrence you are one of the foremost uh
israelites that i'll ever know because
you struggle with god all the time
you're always fighting wrestling etc etc
and uh and
in my life i've wanted to know what can
i learn while i have the capacity to
learn to me that was studying the origin
of the universe because i think
everything springs from the origin
today's my origin day i'm celebrating 50
laps around the sun on this pale blue
dot of a marble as carl sagan called it
so what i want to do is understand how
it all began and i think i can say
without uh maybe hubris that we my
colleagues and i are on the precipice of
not proving god not but may perhaps
falsifying the existence of the biblical
narrative and again you know that i'm
practicing i'm a practicing jew i take
it seriously i taught myself hebrew it
20 years ago at age 30 after being
raised as a catholic altar boy
very very strange upbringing i admit but
i wanted to know because i think this is
the most important question of all and
it's not at all clear settled in my mind
now how do we do that well we do that by
using experiments that have the
capability not to see light not to see
neutrinos not to see meteorites the only
little bits of scraps that nature or god
if you will gives us to scrutinize here
with our minds brains computers on earth
and that's the oldest light in the
universe called the cosmic microwave
background radiation which is slightly
older than me
at
13.8 billion years old and with this
radiation we can imprint upon it uh the
potential uh imprint of a earlier epoch
called the epic of grand unification and
perhaps an earlier outback to that
called the inflationary epoch if that
were true
these photons would expose waves of
gravity not neutrinos not light waves of
gravity eric would shake up the universe
reverberate it and imprint upon the cmb
that i study
a particular type of polarization
again with the plosives
and that signal would in effect falsify
all these other narratives and i've come
to appreciate in what i call the assayer
project which you help me kind of
crystallize what i'm doing with that
that's an homage to my hero galileo
galilei um
way back when in 1623 he wrote the book
el sagittari which means the assayer
what is a nascare eric it's a guy with a
hunk of rock and he's told the king has
this hunk of rock another hunk of rock
that's gold in color scrape it off tell
me if it's real and if you're wrong you
know he might cut your head off
in fact if you're right he might cut
your head off and ask air has something
of no value but yet his ability lies in
determining what has potentially you
know vast value in terms of gold versus
worthless stone so experimentalists are
assayers we take these theories in this
case there are five different theories
eric
and i'm hopeful someday you and i can
work out some of the cosmological
implications of of your theory and and
others but uh there's at least five
different alternative narratives
including one by my friend and and your
friend sir roger penrose and that posit
we won't see anything
and so if we did see something we won't
prove god we won't proven but we'll
falsify this narrative that the universe
is cyclical which is a an idea as old at
least as the ancient egyptians three
thousand years ago so they have a pretty
high h index these guys these egyptians
have a very high h index um
so to me that's the most end concomitant
with that eric we also learn about
something called cosmic birefringence
lorenz
and variance uh violation and other
things that we physicists hold sec or
saying so to me that's what keeps me uh
so excited i think the next discoveries
that will move the goal post move the
goal towards the goal line are in
experimental physics and in particular
experimental astrophysics
so
do you uh do you find an eerie parallel
with corinthians whereas said first
uh for now we see through a glass darkly
and later
face to face uh
is in sense the surface of last
scattering and the cosmic microwave
background radiation
um
weirdly uh
well predicted by or or or well
described by seeing through a glass dark
yeah in my previous book losing the
nobel prize i talk about it and i call
it the war of fog
not the fog of war because we're
basically presented
we're basically presented this this very
dark very cloudy image and yet eric it's
all we got and so in one hand people you
know say astronomy is really hard
because there's only uh you know one
star that we know that hosts a planet
that has life on it but we also have
time machines we have telescopes and
these telescopes can take us back in
time so this
i was going to ask you
just in terms of going back in time
how confident are you
that
the language that we have of going
forward and back in time that
effectively we're always thinking about
time as one dimension
the properties of one dimension is that
only dimension one has this ordering
property where you can say so something
is to the left of or to the right of
something else earlier or later now of
course that took a small update in the
form of space time where we have
uh
a bunch of we have a forward light cone
and a backward light cone we have events
that are outside the light cone that are
harder to describe as to whether they're
in our past or our future simultaneity
sort of goes by the way
but is the language of one dimensional
time like going backwards and forwards
in time
potentially causing our minds not to
entertain multiple dimensions of time
yeah that is something i've certainly
thought about how do our kind of
limitations in our brain pan how does
the fact that our eyes are
two-dimensional surfaces uh how does
that impact our ability to perceive
higher dimensions
luckily we have two of them um i think i
think it's fascinating to think about
how
the the lexicon of reality is describing
and also you know in kind of the
escherian hands drawing that you like to
use we're creating reality we're
describing reality we're doing it
simultaneously um i've become and this
is part of the conversation i had with
julian barbour that you'll hear in about
an hour
on my channel dr brian keating on
youtube because he has this notion the
janus point that universe is sort of
symmetrical and that time is is sort of
a byproduct that the problem with time
eric is that um and i think this is a
point made by um
uh professor baez at
riverside i think john carlos bias
anyway he talks about time is sort of a
one form and and when we think of our
entropy rather we talk about entropy
we're used to thinking of it just as a
um you know as a thermodynamic equation
you know uh entropy equals uh as related
to heat and and to work and free energy
uh but he says it should be more
properly thought of as as a one form
that gobbles up time in a sense and the
you know because you can't i i have not
as you have probably wrestled with as
well gotten a good definition of time
and maybe that's because of the
imprisonment in the brain pan of a
one-dimensional thinking creature at
least in that perspective but
what if it was geometric differential
geometric according to biasing or others
and that's the way we thought about it
maybe it could be a two form uh to use
the language that you were just using i
think it's fascinating but it normally
goes hand in hand with entropy so you
hear people like frank wilcek who i know
you've you've talked a lot with and uh
and and the conversation goes around
what's time time is what clocks measure
what do clocks measure changes in time
you know so it's it's tautological it's
circular uh but maybe that's a byproduct
of true reality or maybe it's something
that is just imprinted upon us by this
notion that we're kind of limited in
space
to what contained between our ears
and so another question that
arose when you held up the bottle of the
simon's observatory whiskey
one of the things that's very
interesting
that
is that jim simons
together with ss chern
came up with a new term
um many years ago that
is seemingly um
very happy in dimension three
and it looks like we live in dimension
three but we actually mentioned four
because we have three space one time
dimension
and this thing
if you put in this term you get um
and you vary it to get the equations
that govern it
you get an equation that looks linear in
the curvature in a much the same way
that einstein's equations look linear in
the curvature
yet it's trapped one dimension it's like
four dimensions is pressed up uh on the
on the window pane looking at the candy
store of three dimensions where the
diamond form
is found what do you make of the
possibility that the churn simon's form
could be relevant
to three dimensions to four dimensions
and maybe
because of its nature it looks
einsteinian to my eyes
and of course geometric unity is is
about this in some sense but pulling
back and thinking more broadly
do you think that jim simons came up
with ss churn with a term
that will be related to what goes beyond
einstein
[Music]
do you think it's relevant to physics or
do you think it's an incredibly
frustrating candy store which the child
will never gain access to and that
dimension three is dimension three
dimension four is four and never the
twain shall meet
yeah i think that chern simon's uh you
know form is one of the most
under appreciated even though it's very
much appreciated and and people from the
likes of ed whitton to uh stefan
alexander extol its virtues uh daily uh
but the question is um the new book fear
of the black universe that's right he's
last week's guest on the into the
impossible podcast uh so this this
notion of whether or not we can uh we
can use this apparatus for lack of a
better word to perhaps derive in other
words maybe what replace what einstein
is the limit of is in some abstract
sense that you could characterize more
accurately than i maybe it's the limit
you know the low energy limit or some
some limit of of turn simon's and that
would be fascinating uh and ignoring the
fact that jim simon's almost pretty
naturally gifted with the ability not as
a salesman i mean that has a bad name
but he was the midwife the broker that
really had this ability to link and this
special place in the special time the
place and time of my birth on stony
brook on strong island shout out to
stony brook we've got some long
islanders in the chat room i can tell
brian how are you doing my friend and
the the point is that he was uh he had
this this gift
to
speak to physicists and to
mathematicians and to set down on this
path which i think is still yet
unresolved it's been proven in two
dimensions two plus one dimensions it's
been incredibly useful in all sorts of
things from you know cryptography to
quantum systems to to um you know
multiple nobel prizes related to it but
my question is um you know is there a
and i i don't like as you know i hate to
sacrifice on the altar of falsifiability
but are there are there virtues of it
that can be tested in the theoretical
virtue sense experimentally and so as
you know i've been looking at
implications of that
for the simon's observatory for bicep
for all the other projects along with my
colleagues
and that this comes along for free when
we in other words when we search for
falsifying god we might be able to also
get as as a side benefit you know that
comes along in the in the happy meal we
might get uh this this notion that
parity just as it's not uh respected in
an electromag an electro weak force may
are in the weak force maybe it's not
respected in the electroweak force and
that has some implications uh stemming
from turn signs so to me
this is per and and better yet i've
never told you this but and i'm telling
now to thousands of people right now but
my id maybe this has some some notion to
do with with the origin of times arrow
because as you know and maybe the origin
of matter uh too because as you know
bariogenesis is not just a brilliant
irishman that we both know bariogenesis
uh but it requires certain uh violations
to take place baryon number obviously
but also cp violation and the question
of the protected symmetry of cpt
violation so what if electromagnetism
violates cpt we don't know if it
violates cp but what if it did and you
can only measure that on cosmic scales
it's too small an effect to occur in the
laboratory so what if we could measure
and then what if we say well that's the
only thing that that you know you have a
negative times a negative to make a
positive so maybe time has an asymmetry
as well a a
a discrete symmetry and so in other
words maybe turn simons will come into
play this is total wild speculation from
an experimentalist take it with a huge
grain of salt but i love it maybe it has
i've been functioning as a theorist here
huh i'm a closet theorist you know that
i'm deeply close
mark
i'm deeply in the closet but um but i'm
starting to come out um and uh and part
of that i have to say you know people
like why is keating you know talking to
weinstein somewhere and by the way we
haven't talked about physics in a long
time this is actually very refreshing to
me we talked about aliens over the
summer with our friend michael shermer
we haven't really talked much about
physics
but for me to be uh i think a a
physicist as an experimentalist
theory is kind of my muse in other words
it's
it's what's inspiring me and it's where
i want to go and it's what i try to
guide the the the students that i'm
blessed to mentor um with it with an
investigative inquisitive curiosity and
and i think that's what keeps me going
you asked me you know kind of earlier
what my origin story was so yes that is
very deeply involved and i think it's
one of the most exciting things in all
of science not just in physics or
astrophysics
i look i share your hope it's just that
i believe that part of the problem is
that both einstein and chern simons are
downstream of an abstraction and that
the problem is trying to get from
einstein to
turn simon's is the wrong thing you have
to go upstream to see the relationship
between them
and that we're afraid to do that because
that's what jim didn't do
now i i knew jim before i knew you
strangely um
and
you know the thing that you didn't
mention which we both
know and some people also know is that
if you go to a bio lecture that jim is
hosting in his institute
we usually got this best set of
biological questions to say nothing of
the math questions to say nothing of the
physics questions so he's
it's not so much that he can sell things
it's that he
really has a very fungible intellect
across
multiple different fields he's just so
analytically strong and uncompromising
that
it would be great to see him
as an accidental physicist and i think
about i don't know have you ever looked
at the work of dan quillen in
mathematics on things like fermionic
determinants and and determinate line
bundles
metrics connections there's a guy who's
a mathematician who made a huge
contribution we never talk about him as
a quantum field theory do you think that
there are other great examples of
accidental physicists who change
everything without even realizing that
they're doing physics as per
the bourgeois gentleman
yeah i don't i don't think there's
anyone quite like jim um in that he has
had success in multiple fields in
multiple
levels of each one of these fields you
know from from you know kind of
ordinary pay grade mathematician to
chairman of the department to starting a
university department to starting a
charitable foundation to running a huge
uh successful quantitative to starting
that industry in some sense and then
within that the simon's foundation now
led he's retired so he's out on the golf
course as we speak no i don't think he
plays golf but uh but you know he is now
led by david spurgle colleague and
friend and uh but this this the legacy
that he's cast is one of what he calls
you know kind of pondering peregrination
and one of which discursive curiosity
and and i think you know it's impossible
not to think that um
he's always been like this and yet i
think he's gotten more like i'll i we i
had the honor of taking him to the
simon's observatory site in 2019 to dig
you know kind of the first shovel full
of dirt to ground break and he was there
and i got him to stop smoking for a
whole hour
i told him i convinced him that that
oxygen tank and a cat and a merit
cigarette that he spunk almost
continuously for 60 years would not make
for a very good you know it's not good
to kill your prime donor on the
mountaintop that bears his name but
anyway uh we we were talking and then
we're coming down the mountain he's
talking about how um how abraham lincoln
and was influenced by euclid and i'm
just like this is incredible you know he
could talk about anything and i think
that's really rare and i i view that and
and i do feel quite a big burden because
there's another birthday that looms
large in uh in three years and that's uh
that will be his his 85th birthday
and i want to get him for his birthday
um not a nobel prize but but i do want
to get him um you know a return on his
investment and his belief in my
colleagues and me uh leading this
project to um to to make a difference to
make a discovery to make it to make it
um a dent in the multiverse so to speak
i think that's gonna be that's a lot of
pressure that i feel to deliver to him
and you know i know my chancellor is
watching right now uh he's a wonderful
guy pradeep kaushala thank you very much
for all your support but i really look
to jim he's the one that you know he's
the ultimate tenure committee like i
don't need to i don't need to to please
anyone else other than to deliver the
best scientific results with my
colleagues on his birthday in uh in
three years
and do you believe that
the gym has stepped in and he's done it
i think at brookhaven national lab and
he's done it through you know the way
kavli has done the way archive
a small number of these scientific mega
funders do you think that the government
of the united states
should be doing this work and not
relying on private philanthropy and i
that's it you feel free not to answer
that question because you are partially
funded by the government partially
funded through private philanthropy
i'm very hesitant to push private
philanthropy
it's one of the reasons why i don't want
to push elon i just don't understand why
he doesn't do it i think it's the
government's responsibility not these
people's in part because they take away
the ability to patent or protect your
intellectual property in these areas and
therefore they have to
step in and be equitable to make sure
that people
that they've taken rights away from
uh
are able to function professionally do
you think that we're going down a wrong
path by expecting that
private philanthropy will have to fill
it i think private philanthropy has a
very important role in that it is uh
much more agile it can do things that
that you know public funding can't do
and i don't just mean in terms of
massive amounts or minimal amounts but
it can give it can take away the stigma
as you and i have talked about before
it's kind of concomitant with with
social media imagine a young james clerk
maxwell 1864 he comes up with four
equations that oliver heavy side will
someday you know incorporate with his
name for all time and uh and he says
well how does it work you know there's a
baby popper you know karl popper's
grandchild grandfather is around how
does how can you prove it oh well look
look very closely into the ether and
there are these little gears and
whirlpools and vortices and they
communicate the electro ponderable media
that produce the for it'll be totally
ridiculed he'd be laughed out of play
and what would happen to society eric
what would have been we would have been
delayed for decades until realized well
he can be wrong about something and be
falsified truly falsified if that's such
a concept uh but he can be falsified and
yet he's ultimately correct and so i
wonder you know for for for private
foundations and so forth when they are
funding you know kind of high risk high
reward you know if you go to the nsf or
the doe and god love them i i have been
supported by them my nasa etc uh my
whole life almost and by the way that's
why i feel like i have and maybe you
disagree with this er i think i have a
moral obligation to have a youtube
channel and i think i don't want to say
a moral obligation to other i feel like
i've taken so much from the government
and i haven't taken as much as some but
but i've been blessed to live in this
country and to have the uh the the
megaphone that i have i want to give
back that's why i have the youtube
channel i don't charge any money for it
i put out videos all the time because i
want uh this best educated population
because if we are indeed going to do
whatever you want to do whatever i want
to do
to lead to more human flourishing as it
said i think it's going to require you
know millions of minds to get phds in
science and i know how you feel about
about you know kind of importing people
from uh from different places
you have to be very clear i mean i am
somebody who is married to a
a technical person from overseas
people never understand this you can't
flood a particular market any more than
you can ask a particular passenger on a
plane to open the window at their seat
because they're going to be
differentially affected and the idea
that we're going to open a window right
next to science so that we can flood the
market
in order to
decrease wages as the national academy
of sciences and national science
foundation bizarrely intended during the
reagan administration is the unethical
thing it's not a question of we don't
benefit from people from
coming from abroad no no certainly no
eric i was speaking about people from
new jersey not not from overseas i
appreciate that but
what is that brian
grounds your optimism in science you and
i have both been watching a uh
an inc
institutional degradation do you believe
that we get out of this and that we pull
out of a nosedive do you think we're in
a nosedive are things actually just
getting better and i'm wildly confused
what do you think yeah i know i've been
thinking about this a lot because one
trade i associate with you is is the
trait that ryan holiday upcoming guest
on my podcast past guess in your podcast
um talks about in his new book called
courage is key
and i've been wondering you know like am
i surviving am i thriving in this
environment because maybe i lack the
courage that someone like you or or
someone like uh you know
another scientist might have and you
know the old yiddish proverb applies you
know he who stands in the middle of the
road
gets hit by traffic from both sides so
the question of you know do i take a
stand do i move in one way or another uh
just because i have been you know
relatively uh you know not not forced to
to kind of comment on these epi
scientific phenomena that i think you're
referring to um and i've done so i said
what can i do can i really change social
policy um can i really have uh you know
an impact and and make science i don't
believe science is systemically racist i
think that's a canard i think that's a
trope i think that um there's not a
single scientist i know who says that
they're a racist so by the principle of
of you know excessive symmetry uh how
can the institution be now you could say
well they're all liars but then i say
you know eric when are you going to stop
being an anti-semite well you're not
working on anti-anti-semitism are you
yeah so um so what can i do i can i can
elevate underrepresented voices and i've
done that i think i've had on more uh
scientists and and brilliant thinkers
from uh african american community than
almost any other podcast and i don't do
that you know oh i'm just going to be so
benevolent i love talking to to the
individuals of any caliber and just so
happens that i happen to have been
blessed to have so many amazing
excellent scientists come on my podcast
uh and i talk about i'm not afraid to
talk about race i think that that's an
important thing and and just as uh you
and i have talked about anti-semitism in
the past i think it's something that's
important now the question is does it
become the dominant theme in science i
think that
would undo some of our capacity but i'm
i believe that that science is so
powerful in its potential as you talked
about earlier um
that i i don't worry about it i see the
young people and again i i think that
the young people we're kind of fighting
the wars like no you wouldn't deny that
in 1950s
america it was hard to get a job as a
jew right but what happened well people
grew up and it was better and then they
weren't beholden to the to the racist or
anti-semites that were i think that
we're getting punished now by the
leadership generation that you talked
about the 78 year olds um that were in
bed with racist ideas if not you know
racist so i think our kids don't even
think about it like you know my my my
daughter doesn't think about you know is
this barbie black or not like she just
loves barbie and it happens to be some
of her barbies are black um
just like uh uh you know i i do think
that what's gonna happen is it's just
gonna become a non-issue i think right
now it's tumultuous it's the birth pangs
of some new phase transition hopefully
that will be non-violent and it will be
peaceful but i think we're going to get
into a post-racial you know kind of
obsession that i think is dogging
science now of course you could say i'm
just a white guy and of course it's easy
for me to speak about but again i'm
putting my money where my mouth is i'm
hosting the most brilliant minds
possible i'm trying to elevate that we
created new institutions within the
simon's observatory for the national
society of black physics students to
participate in these are all good things
that's what i can do as a scientist i
can't do i can't radically reshape
social policy i have no interest in
politics that's why i have people from
the radical left radical right i don't
care i'm not interested in their science
and their political ideas i'm interested
what they think about science technology
science fiction etc
it reminds me a little bit of the the
lore around isidore robbie's lab at
columbia back in the day where whether
or not you could get an appointment uh
as an underrepresented group if you were
any good you had a place to hang out at
columbia
and do science and
similar things occurred in the soviet
union under
landau
in physics under gelfond
in mathematics where there's
traditionally been some core group that
says nobody cares let's just talk
science
[Music]
i like to think that we have a diversity
in an inclusion program that
is based around merit but we also have
to recognize that
in particular i'm if i think about emmy
nerder madame wu
vera rubin and others there are clear
examples where the field has shown
that that program doesn't exactly work
and i'm very up for fixing that rather
than coming up with a new program that
says
you know decolonize science or something
like that and becomes intrinsically
crazily political so i think you think
you're choosing the best bet let me just
finish out with the last question
so
when you're 50 years old you have to
report a new number and that handle
changes uh it's kind of a big deal what
are you looking forward to
in the uh second half of your life
and again if if you get to 100 and
swansea get 128 to moses then you're not
even there yet but that's right you're
sort of beginning
the exploration of the second half of
your life
what it was just a wonderful birthday
celebration for you and your wife
what are you looking forward to that
wasn't part of the earlier part of your
life we know how cool it is to strap on
a backpack and travel the world to um
you know to learn to play a new
instrument or a language to embark on a
new career at age 50 what do you think
is opening up that wasn't open before
that's new that's different and that
keeps you excited about progressing and
growing
yeah that's a wonderful question
although i have to correct the record
i've never learned to play an instrument
i could barely play spotify
but besides that you're dead on i have
traveled the world i've been to six of
the seven continents uh have not been to
africa i've been invited but uh
hopefully that will come true in the in
the next 50 years you know it's kind of
cliche what 50 lessons i've learned
you know in 50 years um i think there's
you know uh there's there's a kind of um
breakdown in the talmud of which is the
second holiest book to jews after the
torah the old testament the bible and
that is categorizes the decades of a
human's life and
and it's sort of between 40 and 50
you get this difference between
knowledge and wisdom and i think right
in my earlier youth i kind of squandered
my youth eric not just in the uh that
being the roadie for uh for led zeppelin
at age zero um and the stairway to
heaven leads up on four tour but uh but
actually an la woman also came out one
of my uh uh audience members is telling
la woman by the doors came out which i
know had a huge effect on you as well as
me
but
uh i love that song i love it
so uh
the difference between knowledge and
wisdom i focused on uh way too much on
acquiring knowledge as a young person to
the extent that i ignored my intellect i
mean it's hard to say you know people oh
you're so smart brian you're so you're
the chancellor's distinguished professor
i say i still have to sing the alphabet
song to know what comes after v i mean
it's terrible eric people think i'm
smart it's it's a joke um
but even so in college what did i want
to do i wanted to get into a good grad
school why did you want to get a good
grad school you want to get a good post
doc you want to get a positive positive
so maybe get a assistant professor job
then get a associate to get tenure you
get a nobel prize or chair whatever
it was always about living in the future
and i heard yesterday over tora over
lunch at one of my rabbi's house
and he said uh you know basically
um when you are obsessed with the past
it makes you depressed
when you're obsessed with the future it
makes you anxious
so like can i be obsessed with the
present can i be happy in the present
that's part of the reason why i
gravitate to you and all the guests i've
had on my podcast because
i neglected my education for just
learning as a young person and now i
want to learn now i want to appreciate
and assemble this faculty as i say of
the most brilliant minds and the
multiverse who you can listen to in your
pajamas and you don't have any student
loan debt to pay off at the end i want
to make it all free because
that's all i have i don't have claws i
can't spin a web i don't make honey uh
all i can do is use this intellect that
i'm given so
i'm looking forward to
um to kind of uh some of the some of the
reaping
not the grim reaping but the actual
reaping of the seeds that i planted with
with my uh biological children with my
close friends and family and uh and i
think it's it's it's beyond that now for
the first time maybe why i'm so grateful
cognizant that it could change at any
minute um but i was reminded of this
passage in my bar mitzvah you know i
never had a bar mitzvah because i was an
altar boy in the catholic church
i wasn't i wasn't
all right so on my on my uh 52nd
birthday two years from today i will be
in israel god willing and i will do my
bar mitzvah now this could be as a
practicing agnostic jew but anyway i'm
gonna read my torah portion as jews are
want to do and in my torah portion i
used to think it was crazy it said
i have put before you on this day
life and blessing and death and curse so
that you may choose
life and blessing like who the hell
chooses death like who chooses to be
cursed but i realized eric
maybe i was maybe i wasn't choosing to
live a full life
so now i'm kind of like maybe i just
touched second base you know rounding i
hit the hut the ball out but you know
i've been blessed by whoever you like
maybe on that second wrap around you
know half of the rounding of the bases
maybe i'll i'll appreciate it more i'll
stop and and smell the roses a little
bit more well i've met i've met your
kids and i got to tell you you are an
unbelievably involved loving and caring
father uh
thanks one to no one
i've been mentoring my own son and i
gotta tell you it's incredibly
inspiring that
when you're going through formative
years and everything appears to be going
into a crazy state to find somebody
who's actually functioning as an adult
and an adult male role model is very
hard to find
i saw the amount of care and love that
you approached your birthday with
with your wife sarah lovely lovely
human being
and i just want to say that you know in
terms of doing it right
um
i really appreciate the fact that you've
also done such a wonderful job with this
podcast and i also just want to say
something about courage
i really appreciate when you demonstrate
courage because i know that the system
inside of science is based so much
around
everybody using everything they can to
take each other out
in a way that we don't like to admit
it's not that everybody does it but
it's certainly
an undercurrent in science and when you
take risks
talking to people like julian barbour
garrett lisi
it really it fills my heart and it's
really been wonderful to talk
physics with you
and i hope to do more of that in the
future
because i think
we have things to do that have nothing
to do with loop quantum gravity versus
string theory versus asymptotic freedom
um
there are new
i don't think that it's a it's not a
demo
democratic situation where everybody
gets to contribute but we do need to
listen to more voices and i do think
that what you've done with your podcast
is to let some of those voices
out take them seriously and i think that
your role of the assayer is a really
noble one because in part you're not
looking to use it to ding people you're
using it to try to figure out what's
here it's much more constructive so i
really hope that
the rest of us have a lot to look
forward to in your second half and kola
kavod
well done and thanks for having me on
the program uh it's a huge honor to
celebrate your 50th birthday with you
well thank you eric you've been a huge
role model to me and to millions around
the world i want to thank you for
sharing this day with me and i hope in a
hundred years
we'll be able to say that we both look
pretty good for a bunch of 150 year olds
um for now uh asking everybody to please
check out eric on twitter eric r
weinstein portal podcast
eric weinstein.org and i am on dr brian
keating in about an hour less than an
hour 45 minutes we're talking with
julian barbour a really wide-ranging
intellect another courageous individual
and friend of the show and i just want
to thank everybody it's natural to look
back look forward and i've been looking
forward to this uh with my good buddy
eric and give my best to your lovely
family and my future graduate student
hopefully
inshallah okay bye my brother take care
be well brian happy birthday sir thank
you